the simple ceremony Europe's central
bank performed the changing of the guard
for the past eight years Mario Draghi
has presided over a eurozone threatened
by what many termed an existential
threat to the single currency when
several countries found themselves
virtually bankrupt and begging for
bailouts and a succession of Greek
governments came and went with the
country twice during Draghi's tenure
having to take out vast loans with those
potential disasters averted
now Draghi says his successors future
policy challenges are clear monetary
policy can still achieve its objective
but it can do so faster and with fewer
side effects negative side effects if
fiscal policies are aligned with it
Christine Lagarde was fulsome in her
praise highlighting her predecessors
stewardship of the ECB and saying his
legacy was a call for her to excel
underlying all that you have done is a
genuine commitment to the people of
Europe the euro does not belong to you
you know that it does not belong to the
ECB however well it serves it it belongs
to them to the people of Europe one of
the simplest tasks Christine Lagarde
will perform in her new role here at the
ECB is to have her signature placed on
all the new euro notes in circulation in
stark contrast to the difficulty she'll
face putting her imprint on the entire
eurozone over the next eight years
because there are potential storm clouds
on the horizon some European economists
say she'll face a real challenge if in a
year's time inflation is not higher does
the Draghi mantra still apply which is
whenever inflation under shoes
expectations react given where we are
this is quite difficult so at some point
you will have to decide when she double
down which is to follow dit rule book or
will she rather opt for kind of a
muddling through approach the key
decision-makers on the political level
believe the continent is better place
now than for many years you have taken
audacious decisions both to reinvigorate
credit and to reduce the risks of and to
warn us all of potential deflation in
the year
the theme of this handover was
continuity and the need for a steady
hand at the head of the ECB meaning it
may be some time before christine
lagarde feels the need to ring the
changes
Dominic Kane aljazeera Frank thoughts